foreign
[Music]
there is a beautiful parcel available
right down here by the flats I
appreciate the offer but I have some
matters to look after one confused I
thought you had completed your mission
but you're still running around here
with the same Little Critter
it's complicated
I completed my quest he returned to me
I removed my helmet and now I'm in
apostate which is all the more reason
for you to stay here with us
where you're from you may be an apostate
but here you'd be landed gentry
our people are scattered
like stars in the galaxy
what are we
what do we stand for
being a Mandalorian is not just learning
about how to fight
you also have to know how to navigate
the Galaxy
that way
you'll never be lost
[Applause]
I'm going to Mandalore
so that I may be forgiven for my
transgressions
this is the way
there's something dangerous happening
out there and by the time it becomes big
enough for you to act
it'll be too late
I'm kidding
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]